comme chaque soir nous vous faisons
découvrir une plage de rage cette fois
elle se trouve sur l'île de ré pour
apprécier le banc des bûcherons c'est le
nom de cette plage il faut être patient
et attendre que la mer se retire
christophe de vallans bras à l'inde un
écran il faut franchir l'orée du petit
bois de trousse chemise est arrivé sur
la plage un joli petit coin de ville
d'auray tout ce qui lie à d'agréables et
de tranquille mais ici il se passe bien
autre chose
en un instant d'une mystérieuse poésie
le courant se fait saillant l'océan se
retire pour laisser apparaître le banc
de sable et lentement faire naître une
nouvelle plage j'attends que ça bête
mais je vais jusqu'au bout en même temps
et après on se baigne un peu plus haut
la vôtre plaisir ça devoir se découvrir
votre plage oui parce qu'il n'y a pas
grand monde il ya très peu de gens qui
le font et c'est le meilleur moment
quand il se retournera elle sera là une
plage offertes par la marée basse
un peu magique le bond du bûcheron
reprend ses droits sur l'océan pour
quelques heures et les vacanciers
profitent nous toujours izik temps en
temps quand on est quand on est sur
l'île et puis que les coefficients de
marée permettent aux petits mots
l exigeante finalement cette plage info
que les conditions soient réunies les
conditions soient réunies effectivement
saviez pas qu'elle existait cette plage
c'est la surprise avec la marée d'autres
avaient prévu leur coup
tranquillement jacques et catherine et
schuller petit dériveur sur le banc du
bûcheron que j'ai pour grande abbas et
et dormir là c est maintenant qu à ses
petites croûtes et dormir attendre la
marée du soir pour rentrer naufragés
volontaires le temps d'une marée
juste un petit moment de détente sur
cette plage éphémère
on est un petit peu en avance la
générale ne vaudrait plus dégagé
un petit peu tout la wii et petits
enfants et techniciens le bond du
bûcheron ne sera jamais une plage
ordinaire elle apparaît chaque fois
différent plus ou moins vastes plus ou
moins belles certains jours elle ne se
montre même pas wade heure où personne
n'est là pour la voir elle disparaît ce
soir mais renaîtra dans une douzaine
d'heures on a même instant un peu
mystérieux